So this is Alex Kelly and I'm sitting here with, ah, James
Weissman, having a conversation for the New York Public Library's Oral History Project
visible lives oral histories of the disability experience at Andrew High School Braille and Talking
Book Library. It is March tenth, and I'm
going to start out by asking you, Jim, um, if you could tell me a little
bit about where you come from?
Well, I ah, was born in Manhattan, and grew up in Queens until it was a
.
Junior High School age when I moved to Nassau County and ah
I went to college in Ohio, but aside from that I was living in New York.
Ok.
Do you do you have any memories from those early years
in Queens?
I remember my early life better than my current life.
I had a happy childhood and
I loved,
I lived in Fresh Meadows in Queens. I loved it there. I didn't
realize that it was completely homogenous at the time, I
live in a diverse community at all... I had no clue. I didn't. Um, I thought I lived in
New York City and I was a real New Yorker and then I found out later
in life that in fact I was exposed to very little of New York, including people with disabilities so
for that matter, I didn't know any. Um, but ah, but I was one of those
Cub Scouts, Little League, school sports
school government. You know I did all of it. And
I liked...I liked living in New York area when I was a kid and I took advantage of
you know I went to the World's Fair, and um took the train to ball
games, and I took advantage of New York. My parents were very much into museums. So we got
to see them all.
Lots of Broadway. I had a kind of a privileged
existence that way (male). Ok. So tell me..(female). We weren't rich, but we certaintly weren't poor (male)
so we were able to do those things (male). Yeah (female).
Yeah, yeah, tell me how your parents, a little bit.
My dad was a display manufacturer. He made a
racks for big companies that sold bras and girdles
and ladies' underwear and pantyhose and paperback books and
magazines and
my mom was a homemaker and then worked with him for years but he died very young
he died at fifty-eight. So, um,
My mother just died. She was a widow for thirty years.
Hum... But
neither my brother or I went into business with my dad. We both went our own ways.
He owned his own business. We could've done it but it wasn't for us.
us. Yeah.
So when you made your own way after after Queens. Well I was an English major
in college and I thought I was going to be a writer and as a senior
in college,  a Junior actually in college decided I should be an English teacher
because I had to get a job when I got out of school.
The Vietnam war was on I had a mediocre lottery number
so I didn't know whether I was going to be drafted or not
I assumed I was going to be
and when I was graduating, I student taught for a
while. And realized I was not
enjoying this. I didn't want to do it. It wasn't rewarding
for me and it might have been if I was more mature... but I was twenty two years old
my students were eighteen. It might have been if I was more mature but
I knew I wanted to do something else. I talked to
my father about going to grad school for English literature
writing and he very gently talked me out of it.
Saying, who's going to pay you for that.
and what job will you get when you're done. and I don't know I wasn't that committed
to it obviously so I took the law boards to see how I would do. I did
well enough to go to law school and applied. and as soon as I got , you know I
didn't particularly care for Law students. I liked the subject
matter. I dove in.
You know right away, I knew I didn't like taxation and,
trusts and estates, but I liked constitutional law, and civil rights things
and there was enough in
the law for me there really was. And I knew I had done the right thing.
And I don't think it was a mistake. I'm glad I did it.
Um, I've had
three children, since. Two of them went to Law School
Um,
They're adults and lawyers. Um, I don't, I certainly
didn't make them go. But, I think they were comfortable
with the idea of being a lawyer.  They are not so comfortable now,
actually. One doesn't practice, and one is unhappy.
Or, I wouldn't say unhappy but not happy. Whereas
I, have always, while I have huge frustrations, most of the time
I enjoy what I do. And the frustrations are substantive. Not
because my job is torturing me. Although, my job does
torture me from time to time like everybody else is. Its why they call it work and have
fun. Right yeah. But I do what I want to do for a living
living pretty much and that's not a bad way to do it. It's a luxury and
you don't get paid as much. and, um, when I was younger
younger I was resentful of people making big money and I was but
I'm not going to lie about that but I
I never changed what I did, and, um
I don't feel like I made a mistake.
My, I still have my high school friends many of them probably ten or twelve I see
regularly. No college friends no law school friends. One college friend no law school friend
friends.
And, ah, um
We've all done different things, and, um, well mine is
unusual to a certain extent of what I do for a living. I think that my
friends have seen it develop and think it's normal. And they don't think
about maybe some kind of social crusader just like I don't
.
You know I don't get up every day and say I am a crusader but if you think about it I suppose that's what it is.
it is.
You know all these years that's what it would be. Sometimes it's Don Quixote
and sometimes it's more practical but that's what it is.
So tell me a little bit more detail about what you do and after law school
What happened?  What happened from there?
Well I was working in the Brooklyn district attorney's office when I was in law school and
seemed attractive to me but the city was broke.
at the time and they were not going to hire a new assistant district attorneys because it
was a freeze, and, I decided, I took the bar exam
And I was married and
I took the bar exam and didn't have a job when I graduated.
Wondering what I was going to do and we decided to drive across the country
.
And to deliver a car as a service that you
call him you can deliver people's cars to. A
lot of the West Coast. So my wife and I drove across the country
camping and I had a very good friend that was a
disabled guy.
We were teenagers together in a camp for disabled kids. So the story of how I got
there but he called me and said you want to write a grant proposal to do disability law
. I'm kind of jumping the gun telling you all that. But so that's how I ended up
doing you know work for the Legal Services Corporation which is poverty law
not criminal law.
When I first started with. Hum I should really
back up and tell you how all that evolved.
When I was sixteen. I'm going to be sixty four next
month. When I was sixteen. I
lived in the Harris School District on Long Island. And my
parents wanted me to get a job for the summer or go to homeschool because you can just stay on
land.
And I got to walk around I thought. You know putting groceries
and things and I had to get a job that I could take my bicycle
. So there weren't that many options that seemed like a
good option when I showed up for work they told me that they gave the job to
someone else. There were none of that it was them to
stay put I have a teenage girl that I was hot
for home was working out here I had a day camp
for disabled kids which was bicycle distance from my house
. And she told me I should volunteer.
I have no desire to do it really but I have no alternatives and I asked my parents of
that counted as a job and they said yes so I showed up
and from the very first day he was aware of a world I was
completely unaware.
Of it showed up the first day in a quadruple amputee a man who worked there who
became a very good friend and just passed away at the age of ninety something and now it's
hours Iraqi with just stumps opened up a circuit breaker
box and switched you know this switch on and on all of them is one hour and I was watching
it with his thumb thinking it looks impossible you need a finger with.
To do the job he was doing with it you know like it needs white stone.
How's he doing that. And I watched him do it and I watched them a few more times doing it and
I couldn't understand how he did it
and. I met a lot of disabled kids and disabled
teenagers my age who were either campers or counsellors at this
camp and realized it was pretty much no difference between people with disabilities
and everybody else except asthmatic especially since these were not
intellectually disabled people just physically how in the name of the place was
abilities it was run by Henry disk already who.
It was a congenital amputee born in one thousand twelve
and didn't have limbs to lose twenty seven years old.
And.
Worked with Eleanor Roosevelt and Bernard Baruch training World War
two entities to use limbs and Eleanor
Roosevelt. Kind of took him under way and
he tried to just one break in New York City to give disabled veterans jobs
after the war and their abilities on Long Island and human resources school the whole place is now
called the Henry discarded center. And
. There was a DE CAMP affiliated with the school
and I was a counselor in the camp. One of the counselors wasn't war
of. Genesis imperfecta which is a brittle bone
disease. He never left his house till he was thirteen years old to go to
school. He was a little older than I was that
he had a driver's license.
You know and control handle when you're a teenager and you need to
go the driver's license it's instant and so we
became good friends whose name is Paul he actually became
president of the student body at Hofstra when he went out I think that he did
and. He went to law school.
And we both ended up working for the Legal Services Corporation had
Riley when I drove to California I got a call from him that said you want to write
this proposal with me shortly before that it was a nine hundred
seventy seven. I run into Paul on the street and we'd see each other a few times a
year.
And Secretary California I was a secretary for
Jimmy Carter was refusing to sign what's called
Section five hundred four of the Rehabilitation Act of one thousand nine hundred seventy three
regulations which would have told recipients this was nine hundred seventy seven the law
passed in seventy three it was vetoed by Nixon in seventy two signed by
Nixon in seventy three the same lot which require recipients of federal financial
assistance like libraries for example not to discriminate against people with
disabilities but the concept of nondiscrimination these of the people with disabilities
was some know that nobody knew what a discriminatory practice was
for example or unnecessary patronization.
Unnecessary protectionism. Was viewed
as the milk of human kindness and not as a discriminatory practice
the result is it keeps you out of the mainstream out of the labor force. It
doesn't matter that it's rooted anatomists Why not if you don't get the
job because they think you're pathetic. Not because they hate you if you still don't get the job
. So it took some doing to get the first set of regulations
out at the time there were many disabled Vietnam veterans
who were lobbying for this. Revolt and then set of
regulations and they banded together with the disability
community in the first.
Kind of a. Joint effort to get the rehabilitation
Negri division signed by Secretary Clinton. There were people throwing Purple Hearts
back over the White House fence and there were.
Picketing at California's house is worthless it's churchy than
and I ran into Paul on the street right into California. Oh and I guess the
president relented and signed of the elations And I said hey
congratulations and he said What for. When I was
living on Hudson Street word street. And there's a bar on a cortical puff piece
which is still there it's been there since the beginning of George Washington I think twenty
years and we went to parties and we
started talking. And I said what you mean. How can you not be
excited about this. It's the person on discrimination laws with disabilities he says
a lot about is that a handicapped man and
. He said it's a piece of paper what are you talking about even my life is any different
because of these papers. Now I had already known him probably ten years
in that time we socialized a lot so that I had been into
bars and restaurants and theaters whatever it is with him when people would say to me don't put him
there. And I would say you know purses on which I would say well he
talks.
And think they're jerks. I wouldn't think there ought to be a law.
So it's a political movement or I would just think you
know I don't think I thought much except that they are jerks. But.
If I thought anything it was that if they knew what I knew they wouldn't be
here. I'm.
Calling people fire hazard to Niles and. Because they can't get in the
row or that the table or you know those counties
.
That day puppies we had our first talk. That is a
disabled people in the law and rights.
I have never thought about this stuff.
I know that seems weird because I had ten years of experience with
disability I worked there three summers my whole C.D.O. in high school I did try the net
recreation program for the high school kids would bring in vans and have dances and
and I have a lot of friends from there.
But I have never had a single political thought.
Now granted there was a war going on there were students and it
was all kinds of political things going on around me but even that I was not a big
I don't pay attention to the news I love the whole Watergate thing that was when I was a senior in
college and I was laying on the floor having thrown my back out what
do you mean hearings in Congress and I had already applied to was cool
. And I thought this is what I want to do it but I never thought
that. That way I had this conversation with Paul
. And I realize that I'm
closer to than most disability only because I was exposed
. To realize that exposure was the answer
that discrimination goes away. I've learned a lot more sense
about getting rid of it. That it goes away with exposure
. You.
Know.
It's a blanket a big blanket statement with as many exceptions almost as a
rule but I think the more people see hear and know about other people the less
they fear and hate.
The women's movement.
They granted women sleep with the other half of the population so they have a huge amount of
influence. But even with all that influence it took millennia to change
the way and then think about women. Women have done. They
have. I'm old enough to remember when we faked it. For them to be
socially correct. Hong when women we're talking about
burning brothers. When I was twenty. My friends and I were picturing this
great brawlers future not women's rights. That's what we were thinking of
. By the time I was thirty I got it I really did
.
I didn't just suppress sexist statements because I knew it
was socially incorrect. What politically incorrect.
I knew that it diminished me as a person to say things like that. I wanted to surprise
. Her black people is a little different
but because there is so much more randomness around race and race in the nation
but I think that we just paralleled the women's civil
rights movement and the black civil rights movement in this ability there was no
law in this area or very little law and certainly no interpretation of
that law and that a lot of case law and then a lot of courts coming down and when they did they were on the wrong
side a little on the long road an opinion in one thousand twenty
seven. Talking about why the state has the right to sterilize
imbecile's. Home
it's you know if you read it now you just think oh my God this was written in one thousand
nine hundred but it was in one thousand nine hundred eighty eight I think it was
Oklahoma was finally prohibited from sterilizing repeat offenders
home thinking that it was genetic this was good science. All these things.
Sterilization column one of the loans that we had soldiers to lay down
their lives for the country or asking human missiles is that they give up the right to reproduce.
I'm paraphrasing it wasn't that crass but it was pretty close to
. Home.
People with disabilities were homebound or in institutions. There was no place for them to
go because everything was architecturally and it says a lot of them and even if it was accessible
they couldn't get because or transportation was inaccessible.
I want to work for the Legal Services Corporation it was called Community Action for legal
services in New York.
There were twenty one offices nineteen world protect truly inaccessible to them.
Although the Rehabilitation Act that I told you about before.
Require recipients of federal financial assistance to be accessible to people with disabilities it
was just ignored. We became the enemy of the Legal Services
Corporation in New York while we were advocating. For people with disabilities because
obviously they had as big a problem as the people we were complaining about
. Paul was very garrulous Irish
guy he had the gift of blarney and.
He was single. He spent a lot of nights. And Italians open
others in bars in New York and he ran into a
guy who stated Jacob Javits staff.
Home. Of his name was Peter Avalon.
Can't believe it but I do. I haven't thought about their
guy and whether one man is making them.
Thirty years. Home we're going to point out you know it's at his
New York office pools that we were
driving you know this whole little green gremlin call.
Home it was all banged up and.
We would rightly know it especially one time so we could park in places
so it wasn't running to Jefferson's office going up Third Avenue
when he said what's this that made you know presumption will work
for us.
I don't watch the negative presumptions. He says we're going to Jefferson's
office. And he'll talk to you to get on with it
. Then when I speak up and I'm only a certain to
lose you are. Still feel guilty. For underestimating me and
give us whatever we ask.
When I left.
But I kind of knew there was like you know the truth is I really did and
it was like it was scripted that's exactly what happened.
Exactly.
I would say that the old thought that he had done right by people with disabilities
until he saw a disabled Vietnam veteran throwing the medals back to
California demonstrations.
And he realized that we had to help people with disabilities.
What could he do. We told him that Legal Services Corporation
which is receives direct appropriation in Congress it's agency like
H.H.S. for education. She said something to one of the few agencies like
little programs.
They think you nothing for people with disabilities inside their offices and we want
to set up a wrong office. And this is the
traditional poor people's legal services in an accessible say it'll be a
really good sign language interpreter is for their people when we need them home. It will
provide Breland large print materials to clients and
it will be physically possible to workers and they will do landlord tenant
on Welfare and Social Security and S.S.I. and Medicaid and all those poor
people. Kind of issues. Great to hear
there was a you know he got Congressman B.I.G. from the Bronx who was on the Appropriations
Committee that would lead services to ask what.
Are they doing for people with disabilities and they said they didn't know
. The people from the Legal Services Corporation who testified
she said well why don't we adjourn so you can find out and then you'll come back and of course they do nothing. So
they came back and so we have this program in New York were thinking of and that was us and
so we got two hundred seventy five thousand dollars from the Legal Services Corporation
which is like two million dollars now. I mean think about the year it was I was making
fourteen thousand nine hundred seventy seven he said.
So it was fourteen. New Lloyd and I think I got a bump when the
bar results came in but not much bigger than fifteen pie or something.
Paul is making a little more home but both of us winning under
twenty thousand dollars.
Believe it or not of them it happened I went out to eat I went to a movie I had a great life. My
wife worked we had enough my home
.
When we open the door first thing that it was hire somebody knew that what
these women lawyers and.
You know we thought we knew what we wanted to do go in and out of the wars so we had to hire out the worst
basically to live together and we did and we fired one
and it was weird and irony of course but we did get it done in the
Legal Services Corporation will not let us separately incorporated. So they took our
money and. I'm not being unfair when I
say I wasted a lot of that they bought furniture for their offices with some of them
which really bothered me including one of them would shag carpet
which was like the world but of course which has a lot of logic over
so it was even more offensive to us because of their home and it was a poverty
law office by blood tests was really it was also the fish
was silly to that but when you get our doors open
.
And when we did those traditional cases came in. A
year but also. With people who said
well I won't write to me because I'm on crutches and he thinks I'm going to fall down and so on.
My son goes to P.S. twenty six but I can't get into P.T.A. meetings
because I'm going to work and school is illegal. I can I
can get a job but I have no transportation to and from. And eat
all these huge systemic discrimination issues walked in the
door.
So they're fascinating people fascinating people
.
So weak but I don't need to tell you about all my early clients and what
happens at home.
I will tell you about some of the early cases later on you know how weird they are when you have
no home.
But I met fascinating people with disabilities.
One of them was a couple that came in for exams who is a
P.H.D. law professor at New College of Engineering
and she was post-polio on about.
Four feet tall on crutches and braces Swenson who was like braces and
had gone through her childhood to adulthood this way and gotten through college and got no
degrees and her boyfriend Michael Imperioli who was an educated
guy who was a sweetheart of a person and very dedicated to Frieda who's
hemiplegic from a stroke and they were very involved with
transportation advocacy and getting people on it.
And. They talked me into going to a
hearing.
In September one thousand nine hundred ninety seven at a hotel that was on top of Grand
Central Station. It was even called a commoner or the more I.Q. and then
public lavatory.
And. You know now it's all
right that it was a different. Town
. And it was a public hearing for the
M.T.A. to get federal financial assistance. And at the time it is still the rule they have to
have these public hearings to seek public input and they were buying these smaller
buses for use on Staten Island. And a group of physically disabled
people who had signed up to testify to encourage
M.T.A. to buy accessible buses with buses for the small
programs in Staten Island and see how it works. And while
they were testifying the M.T.A. board was ignoring them
. They were talking to each other they were getting up and leaving without
saying Excuse me. You know I'm going to the bathroom or get coffee whatever it is
but it was like this doesn't matter and it was really clear and it was it was
remarkably offensive. To these people is this Ph D.
. Who's testifying and she's being ignored. But
some political hack home from the front of the room I just was so
offended by it got under my skin and I thought we ought to do something.
I did but you know life gets in the way
and I got about a year later I can remember Paul and I talking to each other.
Paul said although Clement you do transportation like we're going to change the world.
And I did get very involved in the transit stuff at least emotionally and intellectually
if not legally and from that day on. I left the
job. In seventy nine and went to work for this new
program in government Kerry's office they recruited me
away from where I was called in New York State advocate for the disabled that didn't exist
before and you're going to keep the office was in the World
Trade Center are you going to keep staying honest about
disability they said you're going to spearhead our attack we're going to make the world a good place to
be with this because we need somebody like you. Hi I had a lunatic who was
who only strained. Home
. I knew when I made a horrible
my wife who's now ex wife pregnant. With our
first and I had just quit a job and I knew I wasn't leaving this one
so had too much one's ability and now think of twenty five thousand dollars and I have
health benefits have a tie and then a state employee.
But I hate it. When we were writing this long
piece on the rights of people with disabilities in New York State.
They try to put all the laws in one place because that hadn't been done and now
they're involved in it and we had a meeting in our
office with people from eastern
Asia and the U.S. architectural and transportation that is compliance
board that's called the access board now in Washington the right standards
for accessible design.
And
.
At some point I said in the meeting to the disabled people
Well of New York doesn't do that issue new state doesn't do that state
because the states are.
All well we had a break for lunch and.
I. Was directing them in the World Trade Center there were express elevators and
locals and Sky counting rooms in the forty fourth floor and Sky lobbies
and these people where I will meet them for lunch I said Harold My boss wants to
talk to me but I'll join you. What he does he won't be joining us.
And those dishonest home to that and those people want to live. Harold and
I went in his office and he started shrieking at me but he only three
and he said you work for the state are you counseling people to stay
I said well first of all we'd be wrong if there was a mom telling them that we're doing an illegal day
. Right.
But your job is and it was basically the exact purpose
of the comma to protect the government to keep people discipline is a way you know that
so I went to the men's room before we began the meeting again and I was cannot make the
afternoon session and he told me he was trusting me to do the right thing and I
said you can only trust me to do the right thing.
To do the wrong thing you know. Before we went
to the meeting I went to the men's room and I'm going to tell him Oakley who is a quadriplegic Marine
given that. Said here are that
stateside while he was in the Marines.
What are you going to do when we barely knew each other but we did notice
what I said about what he said about this job. It's one minute because we don't like it you
. Know it was a mistake and he goes Well if you can leave
Terry you know just quit jobs my wife is pregnant I need
benefits I can't quit but if you had a job you would
leave.
Well the next day I got a call from the executive director of East and
whose name was Jim Peters. I went over there for an interview
.
He said How much do you make the first thing he said was Why do you want to do this
and I say.
I am wrong and he said well you know the first thing you do if you work here
. I said Well since I started this work I thought we should sue the transit
. To make meth transit accessible to people with
.
Disabilities.
So that will be what I want to do. Those. Who are new families
disabled and has no way and he said then why do you want to do this
and I said it's the ground floor of the enormous that's about to happen.
And I really got involved I got into it and I said and I could do this and I could be there and I could
and I wasn't talking about myself I should be talking about people with disabilities act like today it
was too late. They don't like you thought it was a good
idea obviously but I thought I could be of each act is what it sounds like
home I was unhappy with the way it came out but that's OK.
He said How much do you make. I said well I'm making twenty five thousand
now because I don't want to make you mad three weeks and he
said. You don't take my.
Clothes at thirty. I learned later I could set a hundred he was and maybe but
you know he had to get better. Like it isn't any so I said
. OK And I said provided they had no health classes. I said provided
I've you know. I can't have children without
. And he said it doesn't you won't forget that she worked herself and
I'm getting help well that's why I can't come until we get these guys in service
connected disabled veterans getting care in the way I was the first male who could walk
in.
The. Various villages there was these
females who work there that were able bodied to home
.
We're going to have right away
. I spent the first summer doing research for the trans it was he who
sued them in September.
I was twenty eight. There was
so touched personally I had a meeting in
New.
YORK.
And I kind of grew up here spent the next
five years doing it. Meanwhile lots of other little
stories and cases and every one of them was eye opening about how the
world who sees people with disabilities. We had a swimming pool
against Levittown where they wouldn't let a woman
who was a medalist in the Paralympics in swimming because she was in the
works.
They would only let her if it is between the hours of twelve and two
which they considered to be low use hours. But even that she had to pass a special
test.
Lifeguard. We met with the plugs commission and one is that
we'll work with another two hundred and then Joe Joe you know I met with the post
commission.
Hand.
I'm laughing at that time it is you also taught me something we were at a hearing in one Police
Plaza touch was going to come down and he was on the Iowa caucuses long while catch
for that to work out how he was the only black guy on the island and this is
what's this got to work right up to me. Shake my hand. And that is
exactly what some people would take in fact his picture while rejecting the play. Yes And as
I told you it's because of events like this
implacable bag if you will cease to say it was but you know table when the
revolution comes just the way. He always used to make I don't
know where he is now.
But. We were able to post commissionaire and we got no where
disabled people would be dangerous to themselves and then use that when I was in the public pools that
position when this went to trial that's what they
said.
We challenge them on it physically disabled people be more likely to jump in what are the
kids women than. People without physical disabilities why would they do
.
That and why would the commission and why would why would it.
Then again it was to themselves. He said.
I mean I have a bit against everybody else he said. Well I've probably distracted
. Which is detrimental to the safety of others. So we asked a very good looking
woman in the suits and distracting and is it just cosmetics who told me
a moment like that but we must take a stand and they be
dangerous to themselves and everyone else the public pool and I left that job and our
successor had to clean it up it took two years to win the.
And there was some law in the area in New York at the time you couldn't
refuse withhold from ordinarily mission to a place of public
support will come to you because of visibility which is exactly what they did. It violates the
law on its face.
No factual examination the facts are stipulated we don't let it in because she is
that.
Helen was going home I had
a woman who was fired from the ladies' shoe store she wanted department store
because she had a double mastectomy and was depressed. OK she came in my
office in the state.
Because when he did says those shoes
. So she must be told.
So there are terribly away I picked up the phone and was sitting
.
Here with Mrs Soandso you know five people for having a mistakenly right
so what is it. I want to do here
. The cheese of the way.
Rosie chop point.
She goes well it wasn't a mistake to me and I think he goes.
To the cancer.
He says yeah you know she was depressed depressing everyone around her. I thought you know I
felt badly about it but I thought for the greater good we
should let it go. Well you know she got a job she
didn't get the job back you know the store was not the same when they realized what had happened.
There were things like I just posted constantly I have it here in one
hundred thirty fourth Street for a guy with wealth and for a
woman with and I say it and I said do you need special
transportation to get it is I can get anything and she said no I
. Was going to meet her out front and she pulled up in a
car and she couldn't park and got out of the
pro-marriage she she got her with a church to go out into the world.
But on the floor in front of her. You know this sounds amazing but it's
true. Was her son who was pushing to get some great
titles then he was also developmentally disabled and not the world's most
coordinated guy and he was afraid to get a break for her
. Well yeah you know it was a
really really weird world I lived in was friends with a disabled couple that lived on
the Lower East Side I went up all of the venom a lie that the Bulls use
words as and when I went to the vet and there was a chair in the middle of the
floor.
I could I mean I can i was it was the chair for those that use your
imagination.
If you know where to go in the desert and we can get next to the
toilet. So he transferred from chair to chair to twelve
. Toilet to charity. And
then there was no extensible design there were no batteries and you know there's really
nothing that perhaps there was no test right there was not enough and
there was no awareness. No need there was a
growing social security disability problem. There was a growing
problem. People had been be institutionalized for many
years. If you remember you don't because you are young but Geraldo
Rivera who is now kind of. A celebrity more than a
news person lover. Yes and he got very involved with a guy named John
Johnson from A.B.C. News here exposing the horror of Willowbrook
and people realize that institutions were huge usually unpopular and
. Some people saw the abuse people sitting in their own feces
home it was all just rocking back and forth day and night. No tension.
And there was a sensitivity to social change because of the women's movement Blackton
socialization movement then that normalization put people in
apartments could fill another table. And they
live in the rest of us but of course put is not free will it's
moving people to a different place. It's really
self-determination and full employment that is what was necessary but that was a
later.
Step I guess. And
. The M.T.A. case.
Was happening while these other cases were grinding their way through world as these little ones
.
Sometimes legal ones. But
When I was a P.T.A. which became United's final Some years ago. I've
never left a job since seventy seven. After three
weeks I gave three weeks notice. So
this is me.
The N.P.A. case. Rhyming its way through it I have to buy the love
from helping me that we were paying.
Through them because you like with big litigation
because it was a video.
Well if you make a motion to dismiss.
And they only motion to dismiss that they don't discriminate against
people with disabilities that they don't post signs that say no to the
lab and they treat everyone even handedly
. So if you can get on a bus by walking up the steps of
crawling up them away.
Oh same thing with train stations.
So how could a non-discrimination will require world
.
Work with this guy Terry Moakley that I told you interviewed me in the men's room and I know that
I was a P.V.A. and he said to me what about
the public buildings because I never actually had a hack
because I was writing that thing through the governor's office but I never I mean I did not think
about using you're going into and what it said was that
building a nine hundred seventy four and incidentally
belittlement came with state of municipal funds that were likely to be used by
people with disabilities.
Had.
TO BE MADE IT SAYS or they will go terminally ill just ignore the law and no one
had sued using. It so we did. And
so I coupled that law saying that the M.T.A. doesn't have to do
anything at all. But once it's doing something.
Just to do it and not discriminatory work so the first thing is you don't have them and they will build new
stations but when they could be made simple to do with
disability according to the public buildings well and according to The New York
state human rights lawyer the one who told you that said you can't withhold any
of the privileges of places of politics the people of this birth and
when you.
But buses these are active words by day when you
act you have done this for a little while
by but if you know by you know that
you want to hear your views on the discrimination is that
. They don't discriminate. I told you they let people cool
and. That what I'm looking for is affirmative action to people with
disabilities not non-discriminatory behavior and the law
doesn't require that it requires even handed treatment went to the
division and it was we lost we've healed.
Actually we won and then it healed and it was reversed in the television in a three two
split of the judges three saying over a reversion to saying what is
nondiscrimination mean when does it need to not just going to throw
all the time this is going on Cotch is opposing us.
He said it would be cheaper to pick up people in limousines and to move buses and subways
except he.
Said it would be cheaper to create something like the excess of a transit program
. Times actually printed this time supposed us both
.
Times actually printed it to pick up a bit is able to present a new study they can wherever they want to
go. Should special transportation program nine dollars a year.
None of that in our own right.
Certainly not for long. It was
primarily between Kutch and Cuomo governor in eighty two.
Almost. Lieutenant Governor.
Doesn't attend governors you get assigned important things so Governor
Kerry assigned him to the representatives of the international year
old he got involved with us a tent caught his imagination
especially transportations and he disagreed with Cox I think I have things to distinguish
from Kutch about when he got elected he promised to straighten this out for us and did
he call us to all and it wasn't here I had already gotten an
injunction stopping motivation tens of waste.
M.J. lied and said it was that also both stations went into the
lowest change that I get probabilities that I got the injunction
. To stop innovation then anything into the
legislature.
Voted to change the law and if you didn't vote for Mr Assemblyman
you know the data station in your area.
I mean they have a lot to play hardball
and Cuomo got elected and said if you get your book that's I mean
. You know. What. We can work it
out it won't work here. There were other disability groups including disabled in
action lawsuits to come after us
on similar subject matter transistors and
.
I think one of the primary one but the more the merrier when you know we wanted
people on the bandwagon.
First of all the way we met was a guy
. In development for Governor
Cuomo. Along with the M.T.A. who came with trucks and easels and
pointers. And drawings of the most difficult
stations to make accessible. Curves stations stations that are a
little in the middle of street Southern elevators and come down into traffic.
How long.
And they talked and talked and talked and contagion
Tomoko. And I kept saying OK
we're going to stay until he works.
And yet finished. And I said Look
.
Until this minute. And years old he said millions of words as walls in
Boston. And show you the harvest stations to do. Then I
say another telling you that are the most expensive
however you know the most difficult patients
. So the only issue is money. So the question is no
longer can weigh. The question is should weigh and
should we shouldn't be there decision it should be the governors
. He's an elected official is this worth or is what you're
saying is it worth it is all of the type of
disability. It's not new and it's always there. Hong
. And. CUOMO kind of
breathed life into our argument by saying I'm sticking with these guys and we
try to make a good deal we've got the most bang for the buck home by
picking stations that we're already going to be one of the most of them while I use
placed and saying they should be maybe sensible.
There's nothing that says that only T.V. stations should be accessible.
Visibilities need as much or more access to the environment than everybody else not
less but the most right thinking liberal Democrats which was all we had in New York
then.
Wouldn't agree to do either station it was just like expensive. If you'd see the New
York Times editorial pages if you would know that there was plenty of room to oppose us and
still be called a liberal than the head of the Liberal Party in New York was on the M.T.A.
board whose name was Steven Boger.
They were all these inaccessible buses three times the original
purchase prior to a regulation that Jimmy Carter put out requiring sensible
buses regular threw it right away so I never really had a home when
he became president and they fell apart and had to be taken off the road. Graumann
flexible buses burger is quoted in The New York Times as saying if we would
have waited to test these buses they would have all had to in the military.
Because it was intelligent to buy crap part in order to deny
people with disability rights. So very charged atmosphere. The
left was fighting the left. There were no politicians that agreed with
us early on except for Ruth messenger who was a city councilwoman then
borrow present and hand him in for mayor of the US to Giuliani.
And how. And.
How to see who was in assemblyman from Queens who I think is still in
jail around lose control or a dead plus
.
Maybe that is yeah I think you might kill him but he was actually a champion of ours and
I I really respected him for that one point he is
much taller than I was in the. We were having an argument in his office and what were you standing
over me and looking down into my face and he said to me Do you realize that I get
real like that without a single disabled. I said Yes you know
it used Democrat from Forest Hills. I know what you can hear. That's
plenty who view to do the right thing. It's a no risk proposition
.
Certainly from a relaxed. And he said to shed.
But we didn't have a lot of us or. All of the one who may mend it legitimate
. People thought there was room to agree with us when he did
.
But he by June one thousand eight hundred four they had begun to order accessible
buses and the legislative session was winding down
. Cuomo wanted an end to the litigation the lifting of the injunction and
renovation of the subway stations. You know to do it we have to work this out. They brought us to
Albany at the end of the legislative session when that happens there's like a
.
Room with all its food to people who work the governor's staff on the second floor of
the White House for a couple of days. They crank all the bills of the assembly in
the Senate and you know it was a don't watch. So
is it your political party did e-mail you know.
Last name it is right it's a mess and they both virtually locked
us this village out of the case and here you know
work it out just prior to that only days. I
got a call from the system to the director of the M.T.A. Richard Rabbit was the
director the chairman of the M.T.A. I have great respect for him.
And he thought we were nuts when people you disagree with. Him
So when people who you respect disagree with you. It's particularly
painful and rubbish. Thinking we were nuts was very
difficult for me I liked it so I thought he was doing it for the City
home of the thousands of years like Joan Rivers as mayor I thought
I really didn't care for him I thought he was too flippant to get
into dismissive of people to Zulus but here we are to have a very good friend with
a disability. Mike that
.
Disagreed with us and.
You know you know if he agreed with you it would change the world because it was new to
me doesn't then it's a huge totally monolithic thing that we kicked around the.
World and.
I got a call from his assistant. Not yet just resigned
and Cuomo installed a new executive director. Named Kyle he
came from Boston. Newton Kyle the kid was
caught it was fighting axis in Boston and New York
. So that was his marching orders I got a call from his assistant I went to their
office. They said.
We're going to do. Buses.
Realize fifty percent of busses will be key stations only create I don't
know and we're going to keep stations.
Is that enough. Yes it.
Was it was a longer conversation we did more particulars and I was satisfied
.
The whole time I'm thinking whatever I don't get these other groups that it's
going to get this is amazing that I have this ability to making a deal with me and they
still have other was with me I won't settle for
. What I won't get a valve yet. We're all done
talking and he says. So you like the deal
yet so you'll sign off on this. Yes good
he says get the other plaintiff's to dismiss them.
I felt terrible I had to call those lawyers I have to say
I acted on my own I was trying to do
a good thing but I made a huge error if you think about it we're getting what we asked
for but I really feel horrible continue out of the process
.
I swear and I hug on my grave swearing although no one asked me that it
was not my intention
. I really thought they'd get whatever writing it and then empty it would be stupid but of course
small and I was miss it didn't make you do when you win you'll be our advocate. Who's that of us
having to be so then we ended up in Albany a few days later
. Those lawyers too. They wanted to kill me but they realize
there's a greater good that we have to be doing and I think they thought I was
appropriately remorseful although I don't know how
. And they locked us in this room. With
food to the president along the way. We had we had
food and we spent two days with them today. Working it
. Out when we were going to. College was still saying it's
cheaper to have this excess arrived at program has people who can use mass
transit if you need to have. So we didn't sue for that but we
got it in the settlement. M.T.A. left up their sleeves and went tight once
paratransit Let's get it and we'll do the mast and the cuts will do the accessory
piece. Well that's going to take a while to make accessible but then services can be set
up so that we can just demand for paratransit right away because
. There was no transportation training going on to get people to
use buses where the few stations existed. Now that's thirty thousand
. Four hundred sixty six hostage
Billy. I'm sorry eighty something planned there will be
one hundred twenty twenty a few a little over one
hundred.
We make a deal. They had a bill signing ceremony that winter in Grand Central
Station and I have the pictures it's great caution Cuomo engine Peter's mother
was because we were to run to V.A. hospital is named James J. Ews
V.A. Medical Center because we were so active up there and getting a new building built
a new hospital the old school was the born on the Fourth of July hospital run covert
wrote about upon the Fourth of July the Tom Cruise movie eventually.
But that new hospital was meant to change gears. Here that it isn't because of his and our
advocacy to get it and to create a state of the art spinal cord injury
unit so there's a lot going on around the transit stopped but the transit was my
focus. I thought I would begin doing long term care.
Issues when I finished transit thing I was kind of sick of the transit thing.
And long term care is still the sleeping giant that's going to cripple
this country in just a few years. My generation the baby
boomers will be old and will live longer than any generation before
it and it will be as manic and out as you make an authentic
heart troubles.
If it's not physically disabled. You know with
crippling diseases. Or patients or whatever happens to
you and there is no system set up to take care of
us. The should have been. Everybody knew this was coming three years ago
. But right now. I've gone through this with my own mothers but I really do know
what happens. He What have you saved.
Just spent on care. Mostly by hiring
. People with no alternative to work in your home with you. Illegal
aliens who don't have any numbers or people
no career oldtimers their own wonderful care
workers and that's you know I'm just saying it's not a career path
. That people cite because that's what they can do
. In the world they live in and you
have to get. If you go into assisted living or nursing
home spend all your assets on Medicaid eligible and end up
with your final use of it as a home hunted. If
you worked your whole life perhaps leave a mistake to your children it's gone on your
final years.
Just like I think it to school programs when my kids were little
and I was a single dad mind you know that was when I was twelve eleven and six with three children
and when my kids were twelve eleven and sex with Preacher with three kids I
didn't have to school programs and they really want to have them and I thought
what all these moms working there are going to be an organized
thing just like this public school. It's starting but if you don't like it when there
is my youngest twenty eight home
. It's starting to lay. For me I
think the next generation will have the blood as you seem to get it I think the next
generation will have it I think my generation will suffer terribly with longer than my
children's generation will take care of themselves. When they see of them
so I think that's what I was going to do and I was going to meetings at the American Planning Association
and learning this so that we can make a change in that creative
benefit program that day or something I don't know what I don't learn. But I've
had really good people in Philadelphia really want us to see
the transit agency and you know we're a membership organization and
I got told it basically and we see Inception. So we
were able to make deals with the two oldest largest
rail systems in the country in one thousand eighty eight lol like the
senator from Connecticut and Tony quel congressman from California
introduced the Americans With Disabilities Act. Paul Hamm
. The guy I worked with. Legal Services like teenage and had moved to
Washington and become the executive director of the National Council on the
disabled which has presidential appointees.
Reagan was president. These were Republicans that were
appointed to the council. Paul wasn't ploy so he is
politics than that. But and Bob Dole was a big supporter of
this.
Reagan told the National Council on it was able to write a report
telling them.
What's necessary for people with disabilities in the U.S. And that report
it was called towards independence and.
It was I would say one hundred days. I mean one of the things I'm
guessing it's payback I still haven't. Hung. Up
and it was pretty massive. And call for a wholesale change of the
when America does things.
To elect says intellectual assistance for people that need
it.
And they said. And Reagan said Thank you. Give me a
bill form. Drafted as if it was an extension
.
Reagan when he got elected formed a task force on regulatory reform
which repealed the Transportation Committee because of that one and was has to be
accessible. He wanted to repeal it was called the Education for all handicapped
children men not to Individuals with Disabilities Education Act
but. Sent a lot different. I don't want to get politically correct
and if you know how he wanted to repeal the regulations and lamenting.
So it's not you the champion of disability rights but he did this thing to
get home.
It came back in the form of Lowell Weicker the only queer those Americans with Disabilities Act.
It was introduced at the end of the legislative session legislative sessions of two years
so it was.
It's like it never was introduced because to be relieved when it was
introduced today everybody yesterday needing time
to mature so it was really just getting it in was the goal.
Tony Coelho made his impassioned speech on the House floor
.
And revealed that he had epilepsy and that he was a seminary student
who was asked to leave the seminary when he had a seizure because they at the time the
church was not regaining.
Disabled people you could remain a priest if you became disabled but at the
time. There were no any of you.
So he was bitter
and somehow the politics against it. He thought they
were doing well. And he did something about it and Lowell Weicker day
the momentum is that.
Kennedy had a developmentally disabled child. Tom Harkin the senator from Iowa who
retired had a deaf brother this is the only war that when people
introduced to the above goals does it when the
sponsors are introduced to people talk about their disabilities or their relatives with
disabilities when they amend the bankruptcy law no one talked about the bankrupt
relatives but people think you must have a disabled relative or something to do this and in
fact it was you know somewhat the
build it up there was an election in eighty nine between Dukakis
.
In eighty eight between occultists and President Bush today said
President Bush has caused most of the things in the vice president but
supported the Americans With Disabilities Act as a candidate for president. Dukakis did not
take a position on the Americans. So then the disability community
held the president pushed him in his word and to his credit he kept it.
Dick Thornburgh was the attorney general of the United States. He's a former governor of Pennsylvania
. He. Really was a champion on this one the as a
disabled child I should say things like him very well as an adult
but he had been through this with a brain damaged child from a car accident
.
And.
He was very helpful. The counsel to the president was named Boyden Gray
Boyden Gray was the counsel to the vice president when he was opposing us.
You know I was the counsel to the president supporting the Americans With Disabilities Act
.
There were no sponsors. Lowell Weicker lost his reelection. Tony Coelho did not
run.
How sponsor became standing where it was cool in the house he
was a real champion. He did it because he was close
and by the time it was over he was a champion in disability rights because
STEPHANOPOULOS A showman was a remarkable woman a young girl and I say girl
because she was a writer.
Who was bright. And terrific and had all the right things
and in the. Senate was Tom.
Harkin's was his is a remarkable man
. He gets it his brother Frank was death and it's still
your brother still smart and he's still capable he got and he ate was a guy
named Bob is hosting was a lawyer in D.C. Now buddies from Long
Island.
We actually played soccer against each other high school didn't realize until the first day when
that I was the transportation guy there were no transportation people on our
side from transit so I became the transportation expert
but I don't I mean I'm not.
That's OK tonight and I will keep saying that you know we need to get on
with it. There was nobody. Because if you work for us we want to getting work from that.
So even though plenty of people agree with us that using the main system
the system that's running anywhere. To take people where they want to go the buses
running train is running well it does make it says we don't need a binder of eagles you
know made to hire new staff
. Who are insuring new vehicles who have exposed liability or fuel legal
that it's already running those kinds of people that agree with us that that's the
cheapest but they will not see a problem.
HOYER And and. Harken and bubbles that was didn't particularly
and you hear this. Americans with Disabilities Act through both houses of Congress
. Congress unlike our state legislature the eight years an
arm of the spill it affects more than one subject matter that
affects places of public accommodation effectiveness
plundered. So there's many committees in Congress that should be dealing with
those things and all of it which is a dysfunctional mess because you keep
hearing on the news but at least the legislature the transportation committee would do the transportation
piece Education Committee would it it could in June why
didn't anybody on a committee this. At
all involved. With the bill ask about any
transportation was filled by controversial putting lives of us
on the head of the committee was going in but Schuster from
Pennsylvania and he was against it says a look at it as
.
He would say look at my knuckles there was great from pushing my mothers which I know she doesn't want all of
us.
Who you know we don't want to point out that she's an old lady.
There was a congressman in Norman Minetta who spent his
childhood at this place prison camp in Wyoming
.
When he was moved from San Francisco because he is of Japanese
descent and. He
actually became friends through the times with the way it only became a
. Sentence.
In Wyoming wins a Republican lie only children
then this one but.
Had been the mayor of San Jose. He had an activist disability community who told him to
make buses because of all of the good and he thought it was the right thing to do and he thought
his committee chair then and how it was very helpful to us in making
transportation accessible. Bubba Silverstein was remarkable
. He took on the White House he took on John Sununu
who was Bush's political operative on me
as I was governor.
When engine hum.
He was a remarkable guy. Very very very very smart
.
On our side we had a loon who works for the is Rights
Project. Of the A.C.L.U. who was the legal brains of
the earth a giant looks nice but there were others who when
she grew up as an Orthodox Jew in New York who went to
Barnard. Continuities that he
studies major and went
to law school. And it was a lesbian
and obviously they handed.
Her hand.
A woman Pat Wright was the grassroots
leader. Of the disabled folks in the
country. From the disability rights education and events fund in
Berkeley California and a woman who still works for the
Justice Department was. Working I think
for epilepsy. And organize the grassroots to come into Washington and has
to play you know and there was a Republican disabled million in a
just indoor inherited his father's money
. And eventually changed parties to be
quite influential in the Republican Party. He was all over the country at his own expense
holding hearings. He called hearings status
where people with disabilities would come and testify about what was wrong in their communities
. And what needed to detect. Then Liz was able to look at
those testimonies and get those people to come to Washington.
Just and a number of years ago but he
. Was a great speaker
and.
At President Bush's zeer and the bill worked its way through
both houses of Congress and twenty two months start to finish
and.
I testified before a lot of committees and lots of those
it's lovely because every committee wanted it had opinions on
only transportation but if you get involved with every committee answer you wind up doing
Judiciary Committee and
.
It was very heady and exciting in one of my first days
to do this was Roe versus Wade day. And on
that day both. Pro-choice groups come to Washington and
demonstrate. And I are very early in the morning and was
behind closed lines and I got home about ten
eleven at night.
And I turned on the news and there was all these women marching
right past the building I was in and I had no idea and it
became an out of work for me that they have no idea what's going on out there. We have to tell
her I still feel that way.
But though it worked its way through both houses there were lots of silly
discussions about whether people with age should be covered. AIDS is God's will it was a
congressman dad of mine from Orange County California and I
thought it was God's will and why would protect people dying of AIDS when God wants them dead
. And what about kids with transfusions we'd say
. Well you know I once I had a neighbor
that carries a gun. We had a work party in the neighborhood to clean up the
neighborhood and he and I were digging a drain line together for a storm and
I noticed he had a holster already in the back of his pants and I said did you bring a
gun to the party and he said I bring a gun.
And then everybody. And I said one of the black people
.
And he hesitated and my other never went one question. It took
one question to stump you don't you think you should be more sophisticated than that
with this philosophy.
That's what happened with the disability stuff who has that so it was debunking
all the time we had a hearing with M.T.A. once where Carol
Bellamy whose name is nothing to you but she was.
She she was a city council president a liberal
Democrat. Now she's the head of UNICEF I think.
But clearly a civil rights champion. She was on the board and was opposing
us and I got called up to testify at this hearing and she was on a
panel that was supposed to be listening to the and and so's as Richard
was telling you that who is the chairman and as I was walking up
. To me she said. You
know a member of the paralyzed and I said no I'm
going to work and she said you're the lawyer. And someone
yelled out from the back of the room I actually know you're going to have to take a rose since passed away
. Who's the guy who had the chair and the veteran I was talking
about what's the matter we can hire lawyers. And
rather to give a look to Carol Bellamy like. Have you shut up.
Would you not if you keep this up we're going to get more of the fact that she
instead said so I can hear you if you would stand
up. I could hear you and he yelled out of going to stand up I wouldn't have to be here
. And it went like that. So when we were
doing.
Yes You know this kind of thing has happened over and over and over again in congressional
offices both with staff and
with.
The elected officials themselves. Congressman Dingell from
Michigan. He's from Detroit.
I believe it was based on an episode of the T.V. show it was about Tourette's
Syndrome. That's what I've heard there was a lawyer who was brilliant in the firm
who screamed out obscenity uncontrollably because of threats.
And it cost him clients or something in big
track Appropriation Committee he didn't want any of those people with Tourettes on Amtrak so he wanted
to change the definition of visibility in the act to beyond the physical disability.
We've got a bunch of disabled people to call Ingles office from Michigan and say
don't do this because we need mental illness and intellectual disabilities covered
and he was furious with us for doing that.
But he influenced they influenced him to.
But it wasn't a done deal. We've got
the president whose name was Claytor to go see Dingle in kinder
and of course there from Hong you know Washington
friendly yet to too. Cold legally to need that kind of protection
that he did. He said we don't put people of the plains of the disabled because you're
dangerous and disruptive Iraq to train and if you're black and you dangerous and disruptive you roll up
can we throw you out because you're black we should be sued. And we should lose. But
we don't do that and we want good people will complain. Because that is a word we don't
need to thank you and then one of the staffers.
Said. Not in the congressman's presence what about people who do
this. What about people who
would you want to interact and end up sitting next to one of those people who eat healthy
we giggled uncomfortably and smiled and I said yes he said you would
. Yes of the hive only seen them once or twice and I do this work all the
time for only two hundred bucks you get to go to
Chicago and go way out of the world.
So the bill worked its way through all the committees. There was an
amendment introduced to exempt food handling industry because of these
. Two having industries an enormous industry
from farming to survey you know airplane flights would
have been ridiculous exemptions since no one can get food aid from food. But
remember everybody dies from AIDS in those days.
It was scary.
Home.
C.D.C. the Centers for Disease Control told Congress they didn't know what they were doing but
it didn't matter they were putting this. Thing passed. But to actually
get voted on. There's an amendment to
Jessie Holmes who was rightly or anti-civil rights guy in
Congress introduced an amendment which they get this
which changed the definition. Of the mission of visibility to
exclude sexual identity disorders almost as well if they want to
be considered disabled. But so it wasn't all that controversial but it was in that kind of the
idea of you know this. Never
feel you will still have a disability so if your disability was they slept with their family was
stuck.
But none of this was necessary because unlike other discrimination disability
discrimination is sometimes job related so that a quadruple amputee
camp is that he's honest even with reasonable accommodation and the beauty of it
here by the way which we can talk about is that it defines a discriminatory practice as the
failure to reasonably accommodate. So you want reasonable per
se you know it's nice that you have that coin
that framework built into the statute. So just treating people even handedly like
M.T.A. are all brought our case was not enough you have to make accommodations.
Those.
Worked its way through Congress and in one thousand nine hundred July
there was going to be a signing ceremony on July twenty sixth. It
was because I thought it might be coming to see me when I wanted it
. And I was taught it and this is
pretty internet increase of long so I got one phone call that said go to the White
House in July twenty sixth at this time and I expected to be in the room if you just saw is
there a little bit with the president of United States. What's inside of them
and I thought this is something I've
. Done it and I flew from
Nantucket to Boston and from Boston the watching the game take you know
what. And in those days you could drive up the driveway that leads to the front of the building
and I did and they told me I had to go around to the south lawn in the back
when a man on the back and in an instant.
I saw thousands of people with disabilities on the west lawn. Platform set
up in front of them.
And I realized just how insane is that you and I actually are and how many
generations of people with disabilities have lived and died to make this
possible and how significant it really was.
Up until then the.
Bills that he was going to be significant to me. Home and for
me and in that instant I don't mean minute I mean instead I realize that
I was like riding the crest of some way that was going to come in you know
that good ideas just happen and I'm lucky to be part of it. I'm riding the
crest of the actual way that's going to bring me a DA in but it's all these
people and it's all his lies lived and living that made it
happen and all the relatives and caregivers and supporters and all the people who really
got that question pushed and pushed so many years.
And.
President Bush got up there with you know significant disabled Republicans which
included this guy just indoor with and change parties.
If you remember the Newt Gingrich Republicans it was just and
good change parties when they were so reactionary.
As one when in the Gingrich years Senate Bill one hundred ninety four first
bill introduced was to repeal big sections of the home
. But we then went to the ghost
hunting and afterwards there was a big party on the Ellipse find a way
very savage introduce you to me. Committee I'd just like one of the
things and she said Senate candidates Jim was he testified at the
G.G. of course he says How are you. I said well you know
I just flew down from the target I was on vacation and
we sailed past. The ends poor I saw the tents set up
for you. Mother wrote a book and he stopped and I
thought well we have the kids you know we were laughing but
you know it was B.S. It was now friends with his son by the way take a
who's an amputee himself twelve years old it was to lead to cancer.
When we last had a bill signing up on the podium was these disabled
Republicans with the president. Home and the president signed a letter of
his name in the initial stages and there's a lot of hands that are souvenirs
and he was passing them out. And people will
want to you know to get one and one of the guys up on the podium with the name of the Reverend
Harold Wilkie who if you look at that famous photograph of President Bush I mean
. Look he's in it and so it was just indoors
. And yes no
arms at all. He's a bilateral amputee at the shoulder and
then he stepped up to get his pen.
When President Bush held it up and he was sitting down and he
was standing up and rebellious looked up to where the forward
Tenet is foot with a sock on and stuck it in his breast pocket
and it's almost an impossibility but I saw That's my note
home it's one of those things that people who eat with their feet can go
all of us were affected by it in those instant Kadian Tappenden
and hundreds of famous picture of it which is copyrighted by the New York Times
and of course you two hundred fifty dollars to use it every day that I've used it once kids are
home for the twentieth anniversary that year we do think of the constitutions
Philadelphia and I include it in a slideshow
but they should. Make it publicly that really started
today.
But all of us are moved by it it's a great metaphor for the disability experience I don't
think because you can't do it they can't do it and I don't think that it can't be
done and there will be people with disabilities put themselves in positions where they
know they will fail. Like jumping in what are they kids women who are lining up to
take a pay and they can't receive. But of course all that was an
instantaneous little metaphor. I know that everyone felt that way except perhaps to
dangle staffer who said what are the people who feel he was thinking
but those not even signed yet one of those guys who leads with the feelings of the president what what's the
world coming to. But I think everybody was pretty moved by the whole thing the celebration was
remarkable banned from the celebration at the White House was hyped along
the legal brains of the outfit because she was the head of the
AIDS Rights Project of the A.C.L.U. and if you remember there was an expression
a card carrying member of the A.C.L.U. like it's the communist party
and she was not going to spiral aboard which I
have always thought was the polls.
She's now media see commissioner she was a vessel that travels for
one hundred years and is now law.
Commissioner will equal to the commission an easy one.
Still brilliant. Still fighting the good fight
. Hone. The first draft of
the National Council was able was a wanted Bob Geldof. He
teaches at the District of Columbia College or is it is tough
.
On many of the people involved in all those that there is a way
that you know weakness because we get to tell the story of work there is a way you
.
Know the whole story of course is all those lives. Countless
disabled people drove their car with a broom to push the guest
room for the breakdown and stewed with their knees and you know there's
all kinds of stories like that of people.
Who work and love then what a low down
home just a lost in the sauce and we don't pay any attention to
them.
There's never going to be statues built to disability rights
pioneers there is a statue of Roosevelt in which it.
Was controversial to fill more than one but
. It's not that kind
of thing. Maybe someday there will be but
.
It's the generations of people who lived and died I don't I don't think
it's the people that knew their pain
debility that was ignored.
Home.
That got the word out.
To change things.
Even this library used to be located in a building with steps when it
.
Was recorded in the library as well as when it was
downtown it was it had steps of the at home you know it's just one
of those things even right thinking people make mistakes. New Times editorial page opposed
they opposed the size of the transportation Jesse Helms got to say even
this New York paper opposed the N.E.A. home
.
We've come a long way.
But right now there is an injunction in the Labor Standards Act for shelter to work for
people with disabilities that they can be paid less than minimum wage. There's an essential
in the Philippines and exactly home care workers who take care of them. They should be paid
less than minimum wage because of preference in the law of their own building for blind people to be
news dealers as if that's a great show or as if
. There is upward mobility and that there's all kinds of
.
Members of the old. When I was in junior high school
and want to learn.
Room one eleven was where developmentally disabled kids and physically disabled kids
. Intellectually capable physically disabled kids were taught
in room one eleven or long with developmentally disabled kids
and the teachers used to joke and you know well
if you want to get sent to well it's not that long
. It's filling up and the world has changed a lot since
and I think it's because of the exposure. But because
so many problems that still exist and you'd think that exposed would have zero
unemployment still sixty five percent amongst disabled adults.
Two kinds of disabled adults is the kind that worked and one of the disabled now get
benefits and then there's the kind of want to work despite that is a vote.
They get lumped together when we say sixty five percent.
But. The employment needle has not moved. Even though we have a
huge problem.
People are going to live longer than ever before they're going to be disabled and they're going to need
places to live and places to work and ways to get.
Their computers and the Internet. One even a dream when I thought it was worth it
.
But.
People would say to me Don't you realize that and thirty years no one's going to be riding the subway
. People will be telecommuting. The idea of travelling to work will
be.
Old only doing it the wrong.
I did worry that by the way I did what they said the thing that my children would
say you know those things that look like elevators in the subway. People tell me you did not even use
that why did we do. Again Larry
I didn't say I couldn't hear but more ridership
now than it was when we started this one hundred thousand over
one hundred twenty thousand people a month ride the bus in which one hundred one thousand trips a
month in addition to that. Even though you're only twenty thousand and
think I'm going to you know that he's in the subway because it's far more than people in which
home. But in addition to that excessive like the paratransit
program which cuts said he can get everybody arrives at nine billion a year
. Last year was six hundred million dollars to give you some sense of the
scale of that that's as much as running the Metro North. So we're talking about a
huge amount of money and that is because
the M.T.A. cheated on station access they wanted to keep as many stations and accessible as
possible. So in to borrow travel. Is almost impossible if you're
physically. Because none of the station access so you call
excessive by excessive ride has no ability to deny rights
. The only way they can. They can have a
building to pass to be constraint they have to keep meeting demand
the reason we wrote the law that way is to make them make stations accessible but it took a whole
generation of transit management to realize. And. They do real
mother claim. It's late and you have a paratransit dependent population
and an elderly community that will not quit. They want to travel they want to go to shows
they want to shop and they are going to college has a right to do it now that it
isn't what the transportation is. So there's huge
demand it's not going away the only solution is getting everybody over that
system. And onto another. So what's the other
. Well it's accessible mass transit and taxis
is our biggest victory of late
bloomer for eleven years eleven months of his
twelve year term. Post acceptable to us.
For the seventeen years.
Five years of war and twelve years with them we fought for this is a bill that says
and some years ago.
Disability rights advocates a Berkeley group who opened the New York office represented
us home we worked with wonderful lawyers
civil and skin to leap in over two years now and and home of the
home. And in the.
Eleventh month. Of the twelfth year. November
decided that he disliked the owners more than us
and there was a thing in Crain's New business that said that he actually said he's going to
cripple an industry to a
. Captain the guy you know when he's no one in there. That's
happening by the way over. But three years
ago. Overblown Bo's objection we got to Andrew Cuomo who created the
green taxis the street help to make twenty percent of the Green he's
accessible and runs the sale of new beginnings two
thousand new taxes all of which would have to be will checked
.
Hong.
So you know the millions would sell for a million. That would raise two billion dollars
The city would get that money and take money from that to pay for the green
taxi accessibility features home the city has only
sold four hundred of those because
Goober has made the value of medallions drop like a rock.
So these three million thirteen thousand taxis the
guy hands were selling for a million at auction. I mean thirteen billion dollars worth of
assets.
Are owned by a taxi was. Certainly not driver's horns
yet. They dropped about
twenty five percent.
Because we were so those hundred fifty thousand so the city and is afraid of
because of the size of the community of yellowjackets is probably shrinking because of
certainly the black car business is shrinking because of over
.
And they don't want to set the bar low on the guy and he's
so delayed but they have to have because in the eleventh month of the
twelfth year we need to do a little bit more litigation. Fifty percent of the excess
of all the twenty twenty. This will change the meaning of the word taxing
. To excess update when that happens
. Despite M.P.'s reluctance Lupton's to jump in with both feet
and despite N.T.A. failure to use transit as a
feeder to mass transit.
To reduce travel times on these long in the US when we come back empty
they would take it to the number one traded Riverdale of the festival and you could take it to the world
where you work and it would be a five dollar paratransit trip. Instead they make an
average ride sixty dollars to the taxpayers and they're over
sixty plus the right it pays them as pets and so
. And so it's on twenty dollars a day. The taxpayer one
used home that's what six hundred million dollars
The regulation which I was on the committee to write.
With us the politician implementing near here and the statute which I helped
write encourages them to use these feeder easily accessible vehicles as feeders
knows what paratransit is feed a service commitment that they know
home and their costs are astronomical.
But taxis were sensible and readily available with G.P.S.
having real time dispatching and you could watch it continue just like overdoes on your
palm.
And yet with avail themselves of this that would be a huge load shift from these giant He
says the road ahead of the veterans to taxis will be a labor
displacement Yes those guys will lose their jobs lots of them work but costs will
go way way down the Eagles' approach is privately.
Could sure privately that fuel privately they're operated by a private individuals in a public
place. In addition to that Medicaid in the five boroughs spends two
hundred million Iowa two thousand and ten dollars two hundred million just to get people to the doc
in which two hundred million a year. Privately operated in the
labs. They would switch to the taxes because that would be done
and nobody is saying it is there
. That savings some of it could be dedicated to pay for the ability futures at
least in the first generation or two and he says he's so that owners don't get
her.
Hoover does not own cars. Hoover is just a
vehicle matcher they dispatched to people and on their car. Who
want to drive they arrange financing for you. If you want to drive for them but they don't own your
car they say they're not covered by the law.
Who is being sued for example for not picking up somebody with a guidebook
Hoover says. Oh that's the Dr
Robinson was going on with what we should be saying and what I told you
read a meeting last week to say is you can still say you're not covered by the
law. Both I and the Justice Department disagree about. The Justice Department
file filed. What state of interest in the guy
below takes I thought about saying they are covered.
So this is not a done deal by any means whether they're covered or not but what
we should be saying is over. We don't care
what the law is. We don't discriminate. We take gay
people. Where they want to go and we take black people where they want to go
and we take people with guide dogs where they want to go because we do the right thing
and if you want to drive with us still here with us or for us depending on
your perspective.
Who would say with I would say for home
. If you want to know these a little. The tenets
of. Working with us that you're going to go away and that would be a
public position and then you would have no qualms with the you know if you
can force that policy. Yeah right you can read you're a good writer once you say one thing
.
Can you imagine if they said we weren't Jews or blacks or gays.
And it's not me it's the brother that wanted blacks over when
they wouldn't even begin to say. But that you say that that is a good moment when
he was mayor said amazing that accessible days he said that the
ride won't be as good and it says that he is.
Religious and but what is
now factory built accessible the sedan
car called the only one that's made by in general that makes the home is for the
military and he is buying them so you can see them in New York with the excess
right paint hung on me and he is buying them in the road worthy
because they you know in New York he really get beat up when you operate twenty four hours
. Hong ten of the empty one.
But.
When. Bloomberg was mayor he invented this concept of the taxi of
tomorrow and having design competition. They awarded the contract in this time from an
inaccessible taxi then made a deal with us which was requires
new taxis to be built shipped sent to a factory to be
retrofitted cut into the car and make them accessible in a very design
in my opinion and. They never want to
take this for the taxi of tomorrow. If they knew that the excess but
it was a last minute decision by the may.
So we're stuck with this
. We're trying to get a bill through city council now to change it
and require site entry vehicles instead of treat
the nissen only allows one other passenger Besides you when it's configured like
inaccessible car has to be up front on the other side of the tension with the driver
. It's just going to take that way if you have two children you can't
even take them again. Hum the empty one is plenty of room
and other designs would be better. So home.
That's the journey there is really a long while there
is yet another hands of other stories in there. But but
. You know we sued new CD
programs. And. We go into the judge's chambers before the first
hearing in which we want to blow hundreds of millions of dollars for the government
and our judges federal district court judge
. So have you driven in this city
there are so many clowns don't you think these puddles did you think it was a
record. You know there's no
legal mandate. Something else. Is a
legal mandate to refer to curbs that are just not doing it. That's not what I
asked you.
Well no.
We don't think so. We think that they should do what they have to do legally and then do
. What we do with it.
You know this just goes on and you get these you know movies and
things that portrayed as Bill again you know we just had a very rare name
windows there to perform with less than what I
actually told it was two winners would be Julianne Moore
with Alzheimer's and even then yeah you know Cumberbatch had
Asperger's the guy in the.
One of the breaking that cycle. Yeah I guess he was a NASCAR is kind of a guy
but not acute enough to win an Oscar for this verdict. But you know I was a
train man you know my left foot and keep winning things and I'm
hardly the first person to point it out but I know it's true.
But disability interesting to people I think when they're not afraid of it.
Obviously mental health issues are out there and people are still scared and
you know it's a mess.
What's what's next for you in your
home.
Well Grandpa OK I got remarried and
I don't know what was three girls and I have three boys and.
They're all getting married having children so I have five and I have grandchildren now
all three of them and they just keep coming. So
I would like to grow old with them and
.
Write all this down one day. It's really been an amazing
odyssey all the people I've met in my life
.
Disability and their stories and I would like to tell it and I would like to
tell the stories of the horrors I work with who are just lost and in
some I still talk to and see so many that it is gone I don't know what happened and then
voted with his buddies and lawyers home and government officials who started neck
out who oppose their bosses who said go away
when it was so easy not to. Those stories.
You know they deserve to be told. And.
You know guys like my example are donated forty eight home
. Didn't see all the things we've seen home. Somebody should write it
down for them and I will do that. Home
.
You know I have a thousand of these stories like you can tell I
really have to be judicious to figure out some format to get it
told and was thinking
I think that it deserves it home
.
You know I see people I felt and where they'd gotten buzzes with the
lift operating and I feel good about it I guess. Today I was
just I was on my way into the city for this.
I work in Queens so I was coming in and my station
to go and say you don't like them either you have has another and I want to go
down you know they don't know the chair. I watched him get over the gap which is a huge
problem. How many stations with his chin to get on the train and I actually
do feel good. I do I have to admit when the lifts her you know her used and
I feel as I do feel good I feel like some personal.
Involvement home.
You know my friends and rose think I had something to do with everything and of course I did
but the things that I did have something to do with I feel good about
things that are nothing to do with I feel good because I feel like just making these arguments paves
the way for other people to be successful that we once had a
deaf mother a mother of a deaf child.
From the Lower East Side as panic woman whose kid was going to be mainstreamed into the
public school system and then been treated at public expense
and private school until then. And they asked to help protect her
child from public school. She's thirteen years old. They'll be picked on
the Hill the whatever and we can help her with it and like
.
We said we hope that when he was in school get what was appropriate
and. It's impossible to explain to mums that interlude grist for
somebody's civil rights.
But that's what that was and I feel I still feel badly about icon's age
thirty something years ago.
We had a guy that we actually had a case against these drive through convenience
stores that the local Dairy Barn on Long Island years ago I don't want it to have a few of them
still when you pull into like up to a sliding door and you can order
from new car groceries and then
. When something is up
. Here you know you can walk to it because they want to make sure they
weren't selling drugs. So we had to study
I think you know Michael and time wanted a studio
. For it and I said I really was against
it I said that we don't it's just not the right feel for me
and she said to keep it out of the newspaper which she did. Oh and we
let her do it but you know the right to drive drunk was not something we want.
We've had lots of these little ones that were hard to
figure out and one of the guys I helped who's still a friend able
to go forward and spoke to was you don't want to be a parole officer who had a history
of seizure disorder years before.
But he had to carry a gun and then with licenses and it was in that six weeks that I worked for the
governor they got it fixed and he would talk
. He went through his whole career as a prose of course no problems with
the disability and retired and keep things he owes it to me and
says things like that. So when that happens which is rare I should say
and you know I really feel for the most part you think about and the next frustration and it is a
mess to clean up and it's going to go problem solved.
But for me you know I'm going to be sixty four next month.
I'm on the board of the American Association of People With Disabilities which on the founder of twenty years ago
and stay I know you'll be interested in what I do
but I would like to withdraw a little bit from the day to day I'm not even
close to doing that.
People talk to me about a tiny you know really close like
you know Thursday night I was stuck on the train in the snowstorm and
I don't like that at all
and. I have a feminine porch
onto the ark. So this is what we were doing in India
and he retired years ago and I actually said he had a health problem.
But I actually said that when he retired but I said to him you can just step back. And
he said you'll know when you're ready. So I think that obviously you can't but
you'll know when you're ready I know now I didn't only met a few years ago but I actually
you know I mean that now I see it. Coming I I feel like a grandpa
. When I was forty I
was you know newly divorced mother forty one and I still thought the whole world
.
How my got a job by the Clinton administration to contain it because it would
have moved to Washington and I.
Thought so what. The whole world's economy there is not anymore I mean there's a lot
about you know the bulk of it's over and I'm happy with what's
happened.
Love all the folks I met along the way. The difficult ones to
elect more you know memory it's easy to take
away all the animosity and pain the the people I don't want to give the
people who won't see what we see. Refuse to see less and
less that is to let. The taxi industry now listens to us
. They're so afraid of who are there working with us now they have a mandate.
There are friends home. It's an unusual way to make a friend but it's a
friend so the enemy of my enemy is my friend.
So you know we made a lot of friends along the way too and we call on them now when we need
them to help us. HONE National Domestic Workers
Alliance.
Has raised the minimum wage for home care workers who are trying to
work so that people don't lose home care hours to help them get a
raise we're hoping they help us get over the hump on
losing all that was the last thing we wanted to pay to put people and institutions
who want to pay for them and community living.
So there's always going to be issues like.
So.
Right now it's not how
long.
I don't believe it. I think they'll always be. Disability
related problems that require.
More than compassion that require understanding and insight into the person but also
some of the people of the future who are working.
Related problems. After all you're doing this like take a principled
stand. And. They. Were
instead to think about men's frustration because I'm sure there were
moments of you know frustration.
Sure what they all yeah I'm not saying
. You know my son asked my grandfather when he was eighty eighty
five grandpa wasn't like to be eighty five and
thought about it.
You know when you're eighty five
. They stopped started it was a big you know we
had and then he won. When you're eighty five and you bend down to dye his shoes you
think of other things to do while you're down there.
You know he couldn't address all of that big life. What's the most
what's the biggest change since you're alive. He asked me once like. That
is pretty big. I don't
. Have a big picture here.
I really need to remove myself a little.
Today's frustration is a solved problem tomorrow
and I promised of the frustration today's place immediately.
Today's happy client is. Usurped by
tomorrow's unhappy client and. Things
change. One of the lawyers I was talking about said Wilensky that
case with us actually represented leprous he's older than I am so happy
represented letters in Hawaii when they were trying to close the only leper colony
in the US home. He's got a much bigger retrospective
than I do you know I would say Sid was represented a lot of
letters. But this is you know these things are huge that we
dealt with but I know there's huge ones to be done. We just don't even know what
they are you know and it'll happen.
Is there any stop.
It's only that this is a great interview as many people as you can interview
. Some people's experiences are so anecdotal and so unique
to themselves that they seem almost irrelevant. But when you put them all
together they make a big picture. So no matter how quirky and weird
story sounds and unique to that individual when you listen
to one hundred you get it.
Yet.
And when you listen and one you know it's easily dismissable
people are too quick to write about people with disabilities because of their perception and also people
know somebody who's disabled and this is the exception. Their brother their sister the lover the
mother that was the one they know it was that guy was disapproved to eat and go.
But then again I just can't do it it's just not true. Just just on when you know that
home. But it takes some perspective to get it and he get
it by talking to people. So like I said even when you're interviewing a guy
that's only talking about himself. His unique experience that's
personal to him when you put them all together and makes this fabric of people with
disabilities who are woven incredibly into the community.
Blatche Jews Italians up down down down he said was that
there's no. Denominator that's not common
. Because gay is able people you know
it's just everywhere. Because of that and because we want people to be
assimilated. They don't stand up and say I'm mad as hell and I'm not going to take it anymore they
only do when there's a problem. My brother's diabetic Isn't think of
themselves disabled till he tries to buy insurance you know over seventy banks and through
his disability.
There will be a lot I say you know but but that's the way it is
.
For taking part in this I feel terrible that I told you
so long.